just a few years ago this place was
known as Nairobi's most dangerous slump
residents in coral gutter lived in
constant fear especially elderly women
like the 65 year old Veronica and Jerry
by the pool America you would hear
screams all the time women were attacked
by boys who had come to rape them
Veronica says the grannies of coral
Gaucho as they call themselves were
regularly targeted superstitious
attackers believed the women were HIV
free and that sex with them could cure
their own infection almost daily one of
those numbers older women was sexually
assaulted raped or murdered squeezes
done man one day we found Martin don't
go dead with broken bottles inside her
body we carried her body to the police
but they closed the gates and didn't let
us in we took her body to the mortuary
and on that day we decided enough is
enough and we women will start helping
ourselves in a poor suburb like
Korogocho elderly women have had to bear
the brunt of society of neglect and
crime it is in this very community that
many of them have been assaulted often
sexually deemed as easy targets and it
is in here that they fight to take
safety into their own hands
ronica has decided to fight back and
others feel the same choral gotchas
grannies who are between 65 and 90 years
old meet once a week to learn martial
arts and defend themselves when I'm
walking down the street and an attacker
approaches this is how I fight I'm proud
to say that I'm a strong elderly woman
[Music]
it is with this pride and dedication
that they have scared of attackers and
raised awareness in their community rape
used to be a daily reality for these
grannies now Veronica says she only
hears of a case every second month and
she will keep on fighting until every
woman young or old feel safe in her
neighborhood mikuni Takuya 10 years from
now this will be a new Korogocho it will
be known is one of the neighborhoods the
people are proud to live in